keine gemeinsame haltung im fall navalny
diskutiert der westen mögliche
sanktionen us-präsident john vermeidet
kritik an russland mehr personal mehr
digitalisierung bund und länder wollen
die gesundheitsämter in der korona
pandemie besser aufstellen und meister
des impressionismus in potsdam sind seit
heute in einer dauer stellen ausstellung
jagd und andere große künstler zu sehen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg genannt und willkommen
zum nachrichtenüberblick an diesem
samstag norbert lehmann ist auch dabei
für den sport solche wunder von mir
welche konsequenzen zieht der westen aus
der vergiftung des russischen
oppositionellen navalny die rufe nach
sanktionen gegen russland werden lauter
auch innerhalb der eu aber einig ist man
sich nicht und der amerikanische
präsident hält sich mit kritik an moskau
zurück lobt lieber seine guten
beziehungen zur präsident putin
und so ist offen ob moskau überhaupt
etwas zu befürchten hat
christoph distel mit details alexej
nawalny seit 16 tagen ist das gift in
seinem körper seit 14 tagen versuchen
deutsche ärzte es heraus zu bekommen
aber noch immer muss eine maschine ihn
baten sind bleibende schäden nicht
auszuschließen
es war nur wie talk das russische
nervengift zweifelsfrei sagt deutschland
und hat alle nato partner entsprechend
informiert mehr aber auch nicht betont
us präsident
bis jetzt haben wir noch kein beweis
bekommen aber ich werde mir das
anschauen ich wäre sehr wütend wenn es
stimmt dass er vergiftet wurde
der kreml aber bleibt dabei unsere ärzte
haben an und immer war nie kein gift
gefunden sondern die deutschen doch
erstmal offenlegen was sie
herausbekommen haben genau das aber wird
nicht geschehen meint cdu
geheimdienstexperte sensburg die
deutschen behörden werden nicht ihre
erkenntnisse und analysen mit russland
teilen weil wir natürlich nach den
erfahrungen von scriba aber auch den
erfahrungen im tiergarten mord nicht
unsere fähigkeiten der russischen seite
offenlegen wollen wir haben deutlich
mehr kompetenzen als manche meinen bei
den nachrichtendiensten und hier kommt
im 2 die gaspipeline von russland nach
deutschland als mögliches druckmittel
ins spiel den bau für zwei jahre
aussetzen fordert etwa
cdu-wirtschaftsexperte märz es wäre ein
klares zeichen an russland es wäre aber
auch meint ein parteikollege auf jeden
fall ein fehler
nord stream zwei muss weiter gebaut
werden wir sind aufeinander angewiesen
wir brauchen diese zusammenarbeit ist
völlig falsch auch in dieser situation
jetzt sich weiter zu trennen
wir brauchen austausche brauchen
gespräche während es dem menschen die
offenbar langsam besser geht bringt der
fall navalny deutschland in die
zwickmühle
anders als nato und eu hat das russland
gegenüber konkret einen trumpf im ärmel
baupause oder gar baustopp in der ostsee
ihn zu ziehen wäre aber nicht ohne
risiko
juristisch und wirtschaftlich nicht mehr
im ausland auch innerhalb von russland
bleiben die stimmen laut die sagen der
kreml schafft aus dem weg was ihm nicht
passt beispiel die provinz sabah acht
flugstunden von moskau entfernt deren
früherer gouverneur sergej vorgang sitzt
seit juli in untersuchungshaft der
vorwurf mehrfacher auftragsmord für
seine anhänger ist klar präsident putin
will ihn loswerden
über den nicht endenden protest in
russlands fernem osten christiansen
putin hat putin ist ein dieb rufen sie
in chabarowsk seit 57 tagen gehen sie
hier jetzt auf die straße
heute waren es wieder tausende protest
gegen präsident putin und die regierung
im weit entfernten moskau die vergiftung
von alexei navalny hat auch hier die
menschen geschockt und sie wissen wer
sich offen gegen das system stellt lebt
gefährlich
ihre namen wollen sie lieber nicht
nennen wir gehen auf die straße für die
freiheit von fogal das leben von navalny
und auch um belarus zu unterstützen für
das alles erst wurde der vom volk
gewählte gouverneur festgenommen dann
die vergiftung von navalny die menschen
wollen klarheit
im juli hatte die festnahme des
beliebten gouverneur sergej fogal
massenproteste ausgelöst der vorwurf vor
15 jahren soll vorgang mehrere morde an
unternehmen in auftrag gegeben haben
der 50 jährige gehört der
rechtspopulistischen und system namen
partei ldpr an
vor zwei jahren hatte er die
gouverneurswahl überraschend gewonnen
und nicht wie sonst üblich der kandidat
der kremlpartei
und fogal habe viel für die region
gemacht sagen sie seine festnahme sei
die späte rache moskaus für die
wahlniederlage wir brauchen eine
ermittlung ob das was man vor gar
vorwirft wirklich passiert ist wir sagen
nein zum machtmissbrauch von den
menschen die das land und die regionen
regieren
es lebe belarus rufen sie noch minsk ist
zwar rund 9000 kilometer entfernt aber
die menschen hier sehen welche wucht
proteste entfalten können außenminister
maas hat in der bild am sonntag
neuwahlen in belarus gefordert er drohte
mit weiteren eu sanktionen sollte der
umstrittene machthaber lukaschenko das
nicht zulassen
auch heute gingen wieder tausende frauen
auf die straßen um gegen lukaschenko zu
demonstrieren
bei friedlichen protesten von studenten
am vormittag soll es wieder polizei
gewalt und festnahmen gegeben haben zur
corona lage in deutschland
die zahl der gemeldeten infektionen ist
auch heute leicht gesunken nach daten
der amerikanischen johns hopkins
universität haben sich im schnitt der
vergangenen woche täglich 1170 menschen
mit dem virus angesteckt das sind zehn
weniger als gestern
dass die bundesrepublik bisher
vergleichsweise gut durch die pandemie
gekommen ist das liegt auch an der
arbeit der gesundheitsämter
sie haben die aufgabe infektionsketten
zu verfolgen und zu durchbrechen
allerdings fehlt dafür nicht nur
personal jetzt verspricht die
bundesregierung mehr mitarbeiter und
eine bessere vernetzung von uwe
berichtet sie arbeiten am limit und das
seit monaten fieberhaft telefoniere die
beschäftigten in deutschland
gesundheitsämtern infizierten und
kontaktpersonen hinterher zu wenig leute
zu wenig geld viele hier wissen kaum
noch wohin der kopf steht doch das soll
sich ändern verspricht der
gesundheitsminister wir wollen vor allem
auch daraus lernen daraus lernen wir den
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst für die
zukunft für die 20er jahre stärken
können deshalb haben bund und länder
ein pakt für den öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst miteinander verhandelt
und beschlossen in den nächsten
zweieinhalb jahren wollen bund und
länder 5.000 neue stellen in den
gesundheitsämtern schaffen ärzte
fachpersonal verwaltungsangestellte
dafür gibt berlin 4 milliarden euro an
länder und kommunen
800 millionen davon sollen in eine
bessere digitale ausstattung fließen
diese pandemie hat gezeigt dass eben der
öffentliche gesundheitsdienst die
gesundheitsämter aber eben auch die
landesbehörden und auch natürlich die
bereiche in den ministerien ein
zentraler baustein eine zentrale säule
unseres gesundheitssystems ist politisch
ist das projekt nicht umstritten die
regierung hätte sich jedoch auch etwas
früher darauf einigen können kritisiert
die linke
es kommt sehr spät aber es kommt endlich
und es ist sehr vernünftig die
gesundheitsämter besser auszustatten
wichtig ist dass das nun nachhaltig
geschieht und dass die finanziellen
aufwendungen nicht bei den städten
kommunen und landkreisen hängen bleiben
bisher sei deutschland glimpflich durch
die krise gekommen nicht zuletzt dank
der gesundheitsämter die pandemie aber
auch darin sind die minister sich einig
solange noch nicht vorüber
9329 menschen sind hierzulande bislang
co at 19 gestorben
für sie möchte bundespräsident
steinmeier eine offizielle
gedenkzeremonie abhalten man müsse den
menschen die angehörige verloren haben
in ihrer trauer helfen sagte steinmeier
dem redaktions netzwerk deutschland über
den rahmen und den richtigen zeitpunkt
werde er mit der bundesregierung und den
anderen verfassungsorganen sprechen
rigorose kontakt verbote und
ausgangssperren all das hat peru in der
korona pandemie bislang wenig geholfen
nach brasilien zählt das land so viele
ansteckungen wie kein anderes in
südamerika mehr als 600 76.000
infizierte und gemessen an der
einwohnerzahl fasst die meisten toten
der welt nahezu 30.000 über die trauer
der angehörigen und die folgen für alle
peruaner berichtet peter theißen
sie waren ein glückliches paar tanja und
hanno die letzte reise der beiden noch
nicht lange her
dann fing sich rahn oder das virus ein
und starb yano verließ das krankenhaus
in einem sack und wurde direkt ins
krematorium gebracht das nächste mal als
ich ihn gesehen habe war er in einer
kleinen box und bei meinem vater war es
genauso gut mischt sich in tanjas trauer
denn in peru ist es üblich die toten
erst einmal aufzubahren abschied zu
nehmen dass sie verbrannt werden ein
schlimmer tabubruch
doch die regierung wusste sich nicht
mehr anders zu helfen und verbot
zwischenzeitlich erdbestattungen weil
man befürchtet dass das virus von den
leichen auf die lebenden überspringt und
weil es kaum noch platz für särge gibt
das alles obwohl peru eigentlich früh
mit strengen ausgangssperren auf die
pandemie reagiert hatte
doch viele menschen können es sich nicht
leisten zu hause zu bleiben
nun hat es schon es ist nicht nur das
virus das die menschen umbringt corona
hat seine helfer das sind die familien
feiern
die treffen in der nachbarschaft immer
härter geht die polizei daher nun vor
und löst illegale zusammenkünfte auf die
stimmung im land immer angespannter kein
verständnis für illegale feiern haben
vor allem diejenigen die dem tod nur
knapp entkommen sind nach hinten um
bringt die leute verstehen dass man
einfach nicht sie sind verantwortungslos
obwohl sie das virus haben verteilen sie
es einfach weiter hier auf der
intensivstation sterben menschen und
andere sind schön
tanja sotelo konnte nicht wirklich
abschied nehmen von ihrem mann
immerhin schenkt der aktion eines
künstlers ihm und anderen ein würdiges
andenken über den straßen von lima vor
sri lanker kämpfen die behörden weiter
gegen eine drohende umweltkatastrophe
und vermelden erste fortschritte
der brand auf dem havarierten frachter
vor der küste sei zwar noch nicht
gelöscht aber unter kontrolle
die new diamond sei in der nacht von der
küste in tiefere gewässer geschleppt
worden
der frachter hat 270.000 tonnen rohöl
rund 1700 tonnen diesel geladen er war
vor zwei tagen nach einer explosion in
brand geraten
der sudan hat für drei monate den
notstand ausgerufen wochenlange
regenfälle haben zu schweren
überflutungen geführt mindestens 99
menschen kamen ums leben mehr als
100.000 häuser sind beschädigt
in dem land im nordosten afrikas gibt es
jedes jahr überschwemmungen
dieses mal sind sie aussergewöhnlich
heftig hierzulande steigt der anteil von
kita kindern die zu hause kein oder kaum
deutsch sprechen mittlerweile trifft das
auf jedes fünfte kita kind zu das geht
aus der antwort des
bundesfamilienministeriums auf eine
anfrage der fdp hervor
die kita schließungen wegen der korona
pandemie hätten die sprachförderung von
kleinkindern vor große herausforderungen
gestellt die fdp fordert mehr geld für
die förderung in leipzig gab es die
zweite nacht in folge ausschreitungen
wieder protestierten einige hundert
demonstranten gegen die räumung
besetzter häuser und wieder endete es in
gewalt barrikaden brannten steine flogen
sechs polizeifahrzeuge wurden beschädigt
acht beamte leicht verletzt
für heute abend hat die linke szene in
leipzig neue kundgebungen angemeldet
jetzt ein ganz anderes thema
impressionismus mehr als 100
meisterwerke aus der sammlung des sap
gründers hasso plattner gibt es ab heute
in potsdam zu sehen
in einer dauerausstellung im barbarino
museum darunter gemälde wie es den yaks
hafen bei sonnenuntergang dieser roos
raureif eine frau macht feuer oder moniz
getreideschober katrin lindner war schon
da ich das wasser spüren und die wärme
die birke von arch und öl gemalt von
bord gesammelt von hasso plattner dem
mitbegründer von sap der auch
leidenschaftlicher sieg
warum so viel wasser in dieser sammlung
also das liegt an mir
rudolf sonnenuntergang picassos blick
aus dem fenster bei seinem ersten besuch
in paris
moniz palazzo ducale die nazis haben das
bild in potsdam beschlagnahmt jetzt
hängt es hier wieder die sammlung hasso
plattners ist weltliga des
impressionismus
neben new york paris und london
das habe ich auch gar nicht erwartet
dass hier so große bilder auf mich
warten hier in potsdam sind sehr
erstaunlich dass es eine privatsammlung
gibt die so groß ist das erfüllt mich
ein bisschen mit dankbarkeit und
allerhöchsten respekt 20 jahre hat hasso
plattner die bilder gesammelt
nun sind sie angekommen in seinem museum
das er extra für sie bauen ließ das
palais barberini im krieg zerstört die
ruinen nach dem krieg gesprengt gern
wäre er selbst gekommen doch corona
hätten mit 10 in kalifornien fest der
sich dank des erfolgs von sap die bilder
leisten konnte musste ja aktien
verkaufen hatte ich plötzlich geld nicht
alles in microsoft investiert das war
ein fehler aber dafür gibt es jetzt eine
schöne kunstsammlung
über 100 originale der impressionisten
die seerosen von monet liegen ihm
besonders am herzen
in seinen privaträumen schaut hasso
plattner jetzt auf kopien 30 jahre
deutsche einheit am dritten oktober ist
es soweit schon jetzt starten die
feierlichkeiten wegen corona fällt das
große bürgerfest aus stattdessen gibt es
ab heute die sogenannte einheits expo
eine freiluftausstellung in potsdam
quer durch die landeshauptstadt finden
sich gläserne paris in denen sich
bundestag bundesrat und die 16
bundesländer präsentieren jetzt zu dir
norbert morgen präsentiert sich nämlich
die fußball nationalmannschaft wieder
gegen die schweiz ja wieder ein spiel
ohne zuschauer im stadion aber die
fernsehzuschauer können das ganze live
bei uns im zdf erleben ab 20 15
nach dem unglücklichen 1 2 1 gegen
spanien im ersten sessions league spiel
ist die ansage von bundestrainer löw
ganz klar ein sieg muss her
tapetenwechsel beim dfb am mittag hat
die mannschaft von joachim löw ihr neues
quartier an der baseler messe bezogen
morgen im st jakob park soll es also
klappen mit dem ersten sieg im zweiten
spiel in der nations league will die
spiele natürlich gewinnen und morgen in
der schweiz gegen die ja natürlich auch
mit der intention in spiel drei punkte
zu machen
lira ist seine gerade erst von einem
kreuzbandriss genesen und gegen spanien
mit der grossen chance zum frühen 1 zu 0
genießt ein seltenes privileg er darf
seine fitness selbst bewerten
entschieden dass ich ihnen morgen
bescheid sagen kurz kurz vorm vom
anpfiff oder bevor wir auf den platz
gehen ob ich glaube ich bereit bin zu
spielen oder nicht
eine personalie hat löw heute schon
verraten im tor steht morgen bernd leno
vom fc arsenal
wir haben ja zum spiel schweiz gegen
deutschland später bei uns im aktuellen
sportstudio um 23 uhr zu gast bei sven
voss die radsportler john degenkolb und
marcel kittel ja und damit zur tour de
france heute die erste der beiden
hochgebirgs etappen in den pyrenäen mit
dem zweiten französischen tagessieg
nospers durfte jubeln einen dämpfer
erlebte dagegen die deutsche
tour-hoffnung emanuel buchmann
lange zeit kam buchmanns team an der
spitze des hauptfeldes das tempo
mitbestimmen
doch als die favoriten für die
gesamtwertung ernst machen vor allem der
junge slowene poker ist der vierte der
letzten tour de france isoliert und ohne
team unterstützung war heute einfach
nicht immer so wenn ich doch noch nicht
bei hundert nach der stuttgart stark an
sich gestern verlorene zeit zurückholen
zwischen den nicht immer kontrollierten
zuschauermassen an konnte perez sucht
den sieg holte sich der franzose peters
der von den großen vorsprung einer
ausreißergruppe bis ins ziel zählen kann
seine erste tour-etappe erfolge in der
gruppe der favoriten mit vorjahressieger
bernal wollte auch buchmann ins ziel
kommen doch verliert er auch sie eine
gute minute und ist jetzt elfter der
gesamtwertung beim qualifying zum großen
preis von italien morgen in monster hat
ferrari erneut enttäuscht sebastian
vettel startet von position 17
sein teamkollege claire von position 13
mercedes wieder ganz vorne am start
lewis hamilton auf der position dahinter
valtteri bottas bei den us open ist jan
lennard struff ausgeschieden angelique
kerber und alexander zverev sind im
achtelfinale
deutschlands bester tennisspieler
brauchte knapp drei stunden und vier
sätze zum sieg über adrian mannarino
erst mit rund drei stunden verspätung
beginnt das match von alexander zverev
das auf der kippe stand weil sein
französischer gegner kontakt zu einem
positiv auf corona getesteten spieler
hatte im ersten satz scheint zverev nach
der langen warterei noch nicht ganz auf
der höhe
er verliert im tie break danach findet
der weltranglistensiebte aber in seinen
rhythmus und gewinnt souverän die
folgenden drei sätze mit 6 4 6 2 und 6 2
im achtelfinale trifft zverev nun auf
den spanier allerhand roter vidovic von
china bei der achtelfinalspiele kerber
uns wäre das morgen und wir werden
berichten zum schluss nur falsches zum
thema entschleunigung in halberstadt im
harz steht die älteste große orgel der
sie spielt seit 2001 das langsamste
musikstück der welt 639 jahre dauert die
komposition des avantgarde künstlers
john cage das nötige fingerspitzengefühl
liefert ein elektromotor und heute war
es wieder soweit der erste ton wechsel
seit sieben jahren
[Musik]
weiter geht es relativ flott bis 2030
finden gleich acht tonwechsel statt
wir halten sie auf dem laufenden morgen
wird es spürbar kühler örtlichen
schauern
die details zum wetter hat gleich ist
intelli im heute journal um viertel vor
elf freut sich marietta slomka auf sie
wir wünschen ihnen noch einen
unbeschwerten samstagabend und sagen
tschüss das machen wenn sie mögen
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter das wetterereignis
an diesem wochenende ist der durchgang
der kaltfront und die hat uns bereits
erreicht es der satelliten film von
heute und auf der rückseite kommt
kühlere luft das sehen sie davor kam im
tagesverlauf warme luft an
dementsprechend war es ja auch im süden
deutschlands wärmer als im norden
schauen wir auf die nacht da gibt es
einige schauer entlang der küsten und
ganz im süden schauer und auch gewitter
dazwischen ist es trocken hier kommt
trotz der kaltfront kaum regen an und
die temperaturen sinken auf fünf grad im
hessischen bergland 14 grad sind es zb
im südwesten deutschlands morgen im
tagesverlauf weitere schauer von
nordwesten her teilweise mit blitz und
donner ganz im süden regnet es auch
teils mal kräftig dazwischen immer noch
trocken und das bei temperaturen von bis
zu 20 grad entlang des rheins und 16
grad an der nordsee die kommenden tage
am montag wird es trocken bleiben weil
16 bis 22 grad immer wieder sonnenschein
dabei und ab dienstag wird es wärmer im
norden schauer zunächst einmal bis 26
grad mittwoch bis 27 grad und dann
wieder neue schauer von westen her damit
ein schöner abend